welcome to this video playing Maradona
again I keep losing to this guy and they
had a fantastic score now and lose all
games and he's constantly constantly
beating me now I really don't know why
okay we had this earlier the variation
earlier means in earlier games and he
had played this strange line with Knight
b3 okay let's let me concentrate yeah I
really don't want to lose against this
again might be three is really not not
that great
let's see f1
hmm yeah okay I went and this was the
strange I know I remember this is this
game it was a really strange game okay I
want to do it differently not the in the
other game I played with Eve form and
here I'm I'm doing it doing it
differently
d5 I want to go Eve form 495
so I should have some good play now
against those pawns of course and the e4
pawn is also something to to have an eye
on okay a5 is typical I don't know if I
should do it here or if I should allow
him to advance okay let's be a bit quick
about this push up a six I'm not sure if
I wanted them Knight to d6 would be a
great regrouping but I don't know if I
can get it in really it doesn't look
like it
what about Bishop g4 by the way I know
it looks weird to trade his his bishop
but I can do that right weakening the
light squares even more
so 93 is not leading to anything
you hate covering the covering of the
pond okay I go
look he's seven he will take on f6 will
be seven would prepare 98 hmm
I don't get this in it seems
Sharon I don't see a clear way forward I
mean I definitely have an okay position
but getting getting something positive
going it's does not seem so easy I mean
yes this is dead Bishop on c1 and so on
or nice but I don't see how I'm I'm
really refuting the his play maybe it's
not possible simply but it feels like I
should have something this is a very
very slowest way to do it maybe g6
wasn't wasn't very successful I just if
I get the night from f6 to d6 no the the
position is fantastic for me but getting
this done is easier said than then
actually performed this looks good
though if v is attacked maybe I can
really prepare this now the the
regrouping I mean yeah I get this in now
926 I'd f1 looked like a mistake really
- I play f5 or not it's not really
necessary to do this is protected
however so and probably I should just
push him push them the kingside and
basically saying okay well I have the
advantage on the queenside as well but
pushing my majority cannot be a mistake
really
so f3 or not maybe this I can take can
take
I can do this come on I don't have
enough time to figure it out this kind
of thing
is really sitting on a ton of weaknesses
g5 also
just say I'm just down on down to one
minute this is the only thing that
worries me the position is really
fantastic yeah I think fantastic nights
and and and things okay take him
debatable this was the best his rook b6
now move don't tell me this as possible
okay didn't didn't go for that my idea
is to attack here now with Luke and
everything everything what I have check
here for Queen d1
hmm I don't see him holding this one is
really really falling and he can just
give one check quite resigned yeah he
just has one check um and and and that's
it
yeah this was this was okay I'm really
satisfied with that I mean I don't think
that this is any good this night
b3 and and stuff it it's not terrible
but I really feel like I should be okay
after that but I don't know exactly how
to play it maybe I should actually look
it up in my in my own book this f4 thing
but rook e8 is probably not a bad move
yeah I don't believe in that really
giving you the e5 square I have a very
very nice structure and you just have to
get the Knight to d6 and now he allows
me maybe Bishop g4 immediately was bet I
am possible h3 what would be an idea and
not know this is really a very one-sided
position where I really have a nice nice
game okay computer is as usual far more
concrete interesting interesting move
threatens f5 and if I get in at five I'm
almost winning I think yeah killing his
bishop and so on so he has to take him
and then the cop wants to do this and
says I'm winning with Queen to h4 yeah
if the computer this is a very concrete
position if the computer says his wins
it does win this is probably probably
the case yeah I didn't see any of that I
just went for for something strategic
that I could understand and how g5 was
good for concrete reasons
this
yeah just attacking ya just attacking
yeah it's very strong I mean clearly
okay I tried for the regrouping and he
allowed that and after that I think I
mean really winning strategically canvas
this is covered I have the majority and
I can push the pawns so I can use my
majority while his pawns are completely
hampered even f3 is right
Wow there so then that was a whatever
server some good moments in this in this
game I had the feeling that it should be
right but well you just have to go for
it it opens up the position activates
the slide and I have concrete attacking
ideas against those very an ammonia
speices f7 seems was better but but I'm
winning here the whole time
so this was a good game I think computer
does not really give me any great
improvement okay well this g5 was
stronger but in at age 5 but I always
kept kept an edge or keep can't control
which is important okay well thanks for
watching